for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so we've already talked about how
we can break down carbs for energy
specifically we talked about breaking
down glucose B glycolysis we've also
talked about how good we can break down
fats or fatty acids specifically for
energy via beta oxidation we can also
break down proteins or amino acids
specifically we could break them down
for energy even though they're not
exactly the go-to as far as energy
sources go okay so when then though
under what conditions are amino acids
oxidize to yield energy in humans and in
other animals well there are three
potential situations the first one being
what's called normal protein turnover
normal protein turnover it's also called
protein recycling protein recycling and
this is just the idea that proteins in
our bodies are routinely being made and
degraded some amino acids that result
from that regular protein turnover might
be catabolized for energy if they're not
being used for the synthesis of other
proteins okay so that's one situation
another situation is during a high
protein diet a high protein diet so this
is just the idea that if someone is
consuming more protein and their body
needs for protein synthesis they'll have
an excess of amino acids and that excess
can be used for energy instead of being
used to build proteins so some might ask
though if there is this excess of amino
acids why not store them like we do for
carbs and fats and the answer is that
amino acids cannot be stored
it's kind of weird right carbs can be
stored as glycogen and fatty acids we
can store and triglycerides but there
isn't an equivalent for amino acids
there's no equivalent that's
dificulty made to store amino acids
amino acids are stored I guess you could
say as as proteins but that's not really
being stored they're being used for
something so there isn't an actual
simple storage form for amino acids
though okay the third situation under
which is this catabolism of amino acids
can occur is during starvation
conditions starvation and why is that
well during starvation carbohydrate and
fat energy is not available it's not
available in high enough quantities or
really at all and so the body begins to
catabolized
cellular protein and a lot of that
protein that it catabolized is coming
from the muscles and so protein is being
broken down into amino acids those amino
acids are then being used for energy
during starvation so those are the three
potential situations okay so let's
scroll down here so basically what we
have is we've got dietary protein that
we break down to give us amino acids
okay and we also have the sort of normal
protein turnover which I'll abbreviate
here is NPT where we're going to take
cellular protein and break it down to
the amino acids and some of those amino
acids will be recycled to build other
cellular proteins but the point is that
we're going to generate amino acids from
breaking down proteins and this
collection of amino acids that we get is
called the amino acid pool or a pool of
amino acids it's a pool that we can use
a me take a take amino acids wrong so
these amino acids are useful for two
reasons one they are a nitrogen source
and two they give us carbon skeleton so
the amino acids were if we shoot over
here to the left we've got the reduced
usable form of nitrogen that is ammonia
or ammonium ion and that can be used for
the biosynthesis of nitrogen containing
compounds because we need to have that
nitrogen available to build compounds
that contain nitrogen in them and so
this could be used to build other amino
acids but it can also be used to build
nucleotides
which of course have nitrogen atom among
other things right there could be other
things that are nitrogen containing
compounds but those are two big ideas
there if the requirement for the
biosynthesis of the nitrogen containing
compounds is exceeded by the amount of
nitrogen if they're basically if there's
more nitrogen than we need to build
these compounds that's bad because
there's an excess an excess of the
ammonium ion is toxic so that ammonium
ion will have to be sort of packaged in
cobalt phosphate which can go through
the urea cycle to eventually be safely
excreted as urea okay
so that part of the amino acids taken
care of oh then what happens to the the
portion that has all the carbons in it
what we get here is the alpha keto acid
with a carbon skeletons the reason
they're called alpha keto acids is
because this is the alpha carbon and the
amino acid and this is the alpha carbon
here the alpha carbon here is a ketone
and alpha keto acid basically though the
carbon skeleton is just a portion of the
amino acid that's everything but the
amino group right so this is the part
that can actually be catabolized for
energy that what basically what happens
is that the carbon skeleton one way or
another feeds its way into the Krebs
cycle and if you recall with the Krebs
cycle we get a bunch of nadh is fadh2s
GTP s so if these carbon skeletons
basically find their way to becoming
intermediates of the Krebs cycle and
they can be oxidized completely to
carbon dioxide and of course give us a
bunch of energy so that's kind of what
we'll be exploring anyway I hope that
video was helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe and
share with friends thank you and happy
studying